vamos a conocer más detalles de lo que
ocurre en la capital ucraniana y en el
resto de todo el país esto con nuestra
enviada especial e irene sabio a kiev
irene que detalles se conocen del avance
de las tropas rusas hasta kiev
pues a quien quiera a una certeza es que
las tropas rusas siguen avanzando no
están tomando posiciones sino que están
avanzando rápidamente lo que indica que
quieren llegar a la capital y según
algunas informaciones ya se encontrarían
en suburbios como tú has dicho este han
bloqueado el acceso en la zona oeste
pero también es cierto que hay
muchísimos rumores y que algunos de
estos son muy difíciles de confirmar en
la inmediatez lo que es una certeza es
que si pasamos una tarde en más
tranquila en la que no escuchamos mucho
se está haciendo muchas explosiones hace
una hora la sirena volvieron a sonar las
sirenas
de alarma y después de eso volvimos a
oír estallidos que significan irene que
llama bloqueado el acceso por el oeste
como planea defenderse la capital
ucraniana
qué significa significa bloquear la vía
de salida hacia el oeste el oeste en la
zona en la que están usando la mayoría
de las personas que se encuentran ahora
ya sea para dirigirse a la ciudad de
libia
o para cruzar la frontera con polonia
que es el caso por ejemplo de que está
permitido para las mujeres y los niños y
también los ancianos con lo cual
significa cerrar a esa vía de acceso que
en este momento algunos ucranianos
consideran como su posibilidad de
sentirse a salvo qué implica esto irene
para la población civil se ven en más
momentos de huida
sí sí por supuesto por supuesto la vía
de acceso hasta esta reciente noticia
que comentábamos antes aparecían
completamente
había embotellamientos en esas vías se
los hubo toda la mañana
digamos la huida de la población se ve
también ahora en las calles aquí en la
misma plaza maidán donde éste nos
encontramos en las cercanías hay hay
poca gente en la calle hay mucho hay un
silencio
bastante inquietante y muchísimas
tiendas la gran mayoría de las tiendas
están cerradas
y no no se sabe cuándo volverán a abrir
lo cual también suponen problemas para
conseguir comida a la vez de qué
hay dificultades por ejemplo para
conseguir una habitación de hotel en
algunos hoteles que han cerrado porque
los trabajadores han decidido que
prefiere estar con sus familias o
también como comentábamos antes huir
hacia otras zonas del país
irene gracias como siempre por el
trabajo que está realizando desde que
hace la capital ucraniana en estos
momentos de tensión un gran abrazo y por
supuesto cuídese mucho irene